all right guys
bang bang i've got bo here super excited
to do this thank you so much for joining
us sir
thanks for having me absolutely let's
jump right into uh
your background what did you do before
privacy.com
yeah um so i started my career as an
engineer at a company called iac
uh which is basically a tech uh private
equity desk holding company they own
match.com uh are you selling match.com
used to own
expedia uh so on vimeo a bunch of other
internet properties
i was within the incubation group there
uh called hatch
uh we basically incubated five to ten
different companies
uh pretty much all of them died except
for one which was tinder
um and so that was sort of my first
exposure to tech and
you know what venture-backed returns and
you know portfolio theory looks like
um afterwards i decided to do my own
thing
uh this is around 2012 2013 uh there's
this really interesting thing called
bitcoin at the time
uh and kind of got interested in the
digital currency
um and came up with my our first idea
which is basically
a bitcoin back debit card um so there
are ton of those now coinbase just
launched one
uh but at the time it's pretty novel
idea um and
you know thinking was like uh people
have bitcoin and it's actually kind of
hard to spend your bitcoin
uh so why not you know bring sort of the
convenience of the
car network rails uh to you know bitcoin
um we talked to something around 50
banks
at that time uh and i would say like our
the responses from the banks came
kind of fell into two categories you had
banks that like didn't know what bitcoin
was and
naturally somewhat risk-averse so yeah
they were like nah this is not for us
let's wait a few years
um and then you banks that like were
pretty you know forward looking
and knew what bitcoin was and they were
like definitely no
like there the door is there um get out
um and so we you know honestly kind of
hit a roadblock there
um and sort of uh refocused a little bit
uh and we're still really interested in
you know improving the financial
infrastructure
and this is where the idea for
privacy.com came out of where um we said
like hey what are like the part the
the valuable parts uh you know a bitcoin
to like a consumer as a spending
instrument so
uh there are two things the security um
it's a push mechanism versus
a pull mechanism and then uh the second
thing is sort of the
privacy and the uh the the the um
you know the pseudonym pseudonymity of
it
um and so uh we basically came up with
the idea to
generate virtual cards on the fly using
a browser extension a mobile app
um and you can set spending controls on
it it's really great for you know
managing subscriptions
sharing cards with friends family
co-workers so on right
um and so this is back in uh 2016-ish
when we launched
um and uh as we scaled the company we
realized that
the infrastructure the issuing
infrastructure uh that we built
our product on top of wasn't really that
stable
so we ended up actually having to build
our own issuer processor so
um quick sort of uh overview on payments
so you swipe a card
uh that card goes from the merchant
acquirer to
the um you know it's a visa mastercard
and then they pass it on to what's
called an issuer processor
that then uh decrypts and uh sort of uh
accepts or declines a transaction so we
actually had to build that entire piece
of infrastructure out
um and over time realize that actually
hey
many other companies uh want what we've
built for ourselves
uh so over the past year and a half or
so
we've actually been opening up an api to
allow developers
uh to issue uh you know credit or debit
cards
uh essentially on the fly uh you know
programmatically
so i love it let's go back to iac you
guys are incubating
tinder what did you learn going through
that process like well if you had to
take away one or two learnings
uh for people who are listening what was
the one or two things you learned
yeah so two things that uh really kind
of stuck out
uh first of all like you know people
always say like there's no such thing as
an overnight success and i
saw that very much firsthand with tinder
uh the if you
sort of looked at the press it seemed
like hey like you know team had like an
idea
uh they built it in a week and boom it
was just like wildfire
like fastest growing app ever you know
on college campuses or whatever right
um behind the scenes it was like a lot
more sort of concerted deliberate it was
kind of like pushing up a boulder up a
hill and then eventually getting enough
uh energy you know as as things you know
started rolling
um so that was like very valuable early
career uh
perspective um seeing that firsthand um
the second thing which is
less obvious which wasn't a direct
takeaway from tinder was
um cap table management is super
important early on
um because uh you know with the
incubation model
what ends up happening is like a lot of
the the incubator
uh basically ends up owning a lot of
company uh and so if your product
doesn't have product market fit
uh really early on uh it's very hard to
capitalize the company
uh you eventually have to recap the
company um
you know to keep going and i think there
are a handful of companies you know and
really good ideas
uh out of the incubator that maybe could
have survived if the cap table was
um a little more equity towards
equitable towards
the team yeah that's awesome and when
you got into
bitcoin when was the first time you
heard about bitcoin or like what kind of
pulled you down the rabbit hole
yeah so um i think i heard about bitcoin
um in college
um or maybe it was like briefly after it
was around that time like 20 20 11 ish
time frame
um and uh it seemed like kind of a toy
at the time
i think everyone thinks you know it kind
of seemed like a toy at the time
um you know people people were um
you know uh you know setting up their
own mining rigs and stuff like that
um which is like really cool and it's
like that that's like super interesting
from a
uh technology perspective um
what got me interested in kind of drew
me to bitcoin originally was actually um
i like many i like many people
had like pretty poor experiences with
like paypal um
as a company i think if you if you're
doing stuff on the internet in like the
mid-2000s
um like i was uh in high school um just
had a pretty bad experience there
uh and saw is kind of an opportunity uh
to kind of
do things differently um so that was the
original kind of hook for me or is like
bad experience how can we make it better
yeah absolutely
and then when people hear privacy.com
the first thing i think of is how the
hell did you get that url
what's that story yeah yeah yeah so that
is a uh
this is a good question um every time
there's a good url there's always a good
story behind it
there there is always a good story i
think um i encourage
uh early stage companies to try to punch
above their weight
on domain because it just lends you a
bunch of credibility
especially if you're doing something
that requires like high trust or in
financial services space
um how we ended up coming up with it was
um
we so we we actually contacted the owner
of the domain um and he wasn't doing it
with
anything with that at the time and we
said hey like you know why don't
we're working on this you know cool new
product and basically pitch the owner
on what we were doing he was excited
about it and basically
invested the domain in the company uh
and you know we had a closet basically
said hey like if we go belly up
or whatever like you can get the domain
back so you know it's a
pretty low risk um you know investment
in that sense especially if you're not
dealing with
anything with the domain for like 10
years absolutely so basically it was
like hey you give us the domain if this
works you'll get some equity
if it doesn't work then we'll give it
back to you yeah exactly and i think
this is also around the time where uh
when uber is really taking off and like
uh you know uber famously got like two
percent traded like two percent
of the company for the domain and that
was like a phenomenal investment so
it was a great case to kind of point to
for us
absolutely well now you just got to go
build the next uber and make them
very very happy right yeah awesome let's
talk about these secure virtual cards so
walk us through the process i'm going to
buy something on the internet
how do i interact with the product yeah
so you sign up you connect a funding
source um
generally sign up takes like you know
three minutes you put in some uh
personal information so that we can uh
comply with the law effectively and run
our kyc processes
um and then you install either our
browse extension or mobile app
um and then anytime you go to a checkout
page there's a little button that shows
up next to the checkout form you click
the button
uh and you can generate a brand new card
number on the fly um as you're creating
the card you can set limits on it you
can have it be a one-time used card so
if you're signing up for a subscription
that you're not sure you want to renew
um it's really good for that kind of use
case um and sort of uh
you know smaller websites where you're
maybe not sure about the security and so
on
got it and so when i'm going to do this
uh what's the risk
to me right like obviously there's a ton
of uh benefits in terms of
it provides much more security and
privacy but what are the risks
associated
um the risks associated with signing up
um you know i mean look i think there's
uh
you know fundamentally there's a social
contract being entered
uh with us where um if we get breached
that is
that is a risk um so you're saying
you're basically saying hey like you
know privacy.com
in exchange for trusting uh you with my
information
um you know you're gonna make my life
more secure more convenient
um and easier um so that's one um i
think another trade-off not necessarily
a risk is uh rewards points
so um some folks are you know rewards
junkies um
and uh you know you don't get credit
card rewards um with our with our
products so that's that's sort of a very
clear downside
yeah and it seems like kind of the
initial use case here
or the experience is very much i go i
set up the card with the parameters
right so i want a one-time use card i
wanted to be able to spend up to a
thousand dollars
i then go to nike.com and i say hey i'm
going to buy 700
worth of this and i basically protected
my privacy and security
by preemptively going and getting this
one-time use card through your platform
uh it would make sense i think and it
sounds like you're already trying to
work on this
where i just go to nike.com and when i
go to check out
nike.com basically automatically does
this
for me kind of in the background so that
my uh
my credit card details or my banking
information is never exposed throughout
that transaction
is that a world where you think like you
know the pie in the sky vision is like
every single website in the internet
will have some version of that
experience
at some point in the future or is that
more dreams than reality and
just we'll never get there um i'm not
sure
yeah so i'm not sure we'll actually ever
get there um
i think what you're seeing that is kind
of interesting is
there are more and more uh different
options that check out now
um that do involve like you know single
used cards so for example
um if you go to peloton and you decide
to
you know do a buy now pay later alone um
or maybe peloton's maybe not a good
example but like
you know you can go to other websites um
and get a you know
sort of point of sale financing and
sometimes like that's dispersed via a
card
that's generated on the fly and it's
actually not only are you getting
financing
uh for the product it's also more secure
because you know it's not
you know you're not entering in your
actual card information
um so yeah and how does this change for
the merchant do they
care or is there any pros or cons versus
whether i'm using my card or using kind
of the
the one-time use or or some sort of
privacy.com virtual card
so you know what we find is like
for uh for bigger merchants the main
thing is actually
like it does help from a convenience
perspective um you know you click the
button
and like you just go um and so that's
that's the main benefit for a merchant
uh larger merchant for smaller merchants
uh we actually find the peace of mind
really helps a lot more so uh you know
if you go to amazon
or like you know um you know walmart or
whatever like maybe you're not that
worried about like what you know what's
happening with your card info
if you're going to like a much smaller
merchant that
does become something that comes up in
people's mind where it's like oh there's
a little apprehension like maybe i
shouldn't be buying this product from
this website
maybe i should be going to amazon or
somewhere else somewhere else to see if
there's a similar product
right so um we find that like it does
actually help with conversion rate
um it's just like not it's sort of
different levers uh depending on who the
merchant is
yeah that makes a ton of sense to me if
basically if you can make your customers
believe
hey we are trustworthy and some you know
whether it's through
uh the url that you have right or
through the the use of virtual cards
things like that uh
conversion would go up talk to me about
this api
uh or set of apis that you guys are
building it seems like that's kind of
stage two for you guys in this business
is using those apis to really try to
scale and become much more of a
like integral part of the infrastructure
of companies
yeah yeah absolutely so um you know i
think
there's a kind of similar analog of
amazon and aws where
um we built all of this infrastructure
uh because if you look at like you know
just in terms of like payment volume uh
we're on track in the us to do 10
trillion dollars
in you know credit debit prepaid card
volume
uh by 2023 uh and 95
plus percent of that is gonna run over
like basically at that point
40 year old companies companies like
fleet core thesis jack henry so on right
they do a great job but like you know
fundamentally it's very old
infrastructure
that makes it relatively hard to
innovate and build new products on top
of you know actual sort of card issuance
um and so we we ended up actually in the
process of building our virtual card
product
had to build um all the pieces around
um issuing um uh
credit or debit cards um or largely
debit cards but we can also support
credit cards
um and finding like tons of other
companies want to do this as well it's
normally a really painful process
so let's say you wanted to um you know
issue
a card uh today it's actually usually a
12 to 18 month process
um and costs on the order of 500k to a
million dollars in terms of expenses and
that's like
legal uh payroll uh setup fees with you
know the various stakeholders
uh and gatekeepers uh so we we we're
sort of looking to dramatically bring
down the cost
of like issuing a card uh with our apis
got it and so what's kind of the vision
there right let's fast forward 10 years
like
you were able to build out the
technology from the api
suite how are you positioned kind of in
the market with all these other players
yeah um so i think it's it's helpful in
some ways to frame this
in the context of uh the acquiring world
because card acquiring is a much
better understood space um if you look
at companies like
uh stripe addion braintree and so on
they've done a really good job on the
acquiring side to make it really dead
simple
for any developer to accept cards online
um the issuer processing space which is
the other side of you know a financial
transaction
on in the card world lags this by
around seven to ten years um so what
they've done
the the add-ins and stripes of the world
in making
uh acquiring processing super product
and developer oriented
we're looking to do for the issuing
processing world
got it and so what is the kind of
concerns
or um the way that this is treated with
uh
law enforcement governments etc right so
the first second that
uh somebody says hey i want to hide my
identity it feels like all of the people
in suits and ties with badges say like
oh you're hiding something
right uh usually that ends up not being
true but
uh that's definitely the reaction and so
one have you guys
seen people saying like why do you need
to use the virtual cards
have you seen kind of nefarious activity
or just how do you think about
uh preventing that anything in that
space
yeah so i mean as a as a financial
services company we obviously
uh take compliance regulation uh
and that all that very seriously um and
in order to operate in the u.s we we
need to
um and so that is the integral part of
like you know kind of what we've built
um you know that
that is um uh so that's one piece of it
we sort of
we we need to have a compliant you know
kyc and
uh aml and uh you know bsa policy
um as a company and as with all other
card
card issuing companies um on the on the
other hand
i do think sort of the definition of
privacy and
you know how important that is is
changing um
as everything is going digital so um if
you think about it like
uh we're we're in a world today where
not to sort of get super tinfoil
hatty but uh everything you know the
cost of storage
and the cost of computing are both
effectively going towards zero
and what that means is like you know
basically uh you know everything that
you do online
can be tracked and can be searched
pretty quickly um
and so i think that is kind of a
paradigm shift
that uh it has has come uh and maybe the
full effect of it hasn't been felt uh
whereas like previously you know
if you go go to a local bodega or
somewhere and you're like hey i want to
buy something cash like that's
that's pretty you know that's that's
totally legal maybe you're buying a pack
of gum or
you know a bag of cheetos or whatever
right that's you're buying something
totally legal but it's also private um
and
that's a right that's kind of being
eroded i think in in today's world
yeah and it also feels like the only way
to fight back against this is gonna be
with technology
right like like there's not gonna be
some uh hey let's go negotiate uh
in the halls of congress or something
like it definitely feels like
uh the non-technology momentum
is against those who believe in privacy
individual freedom
etc and the last remaining kind of uh
you know parachute lifeboat whatever is
to build the technology just to make
this standard across
uh these various technology companies
right absolutely absolutely i mean
that's why
i'm super bullish on the space i think
if you look at like
you know investors i think investors are
starting to come around it but i think
for a really long time there's actually
this received wisdom
you know around like this around the
privacy and security space where you
know all the tools out there
were like super user unfriendly and
accessible um
and as a result like no one wanted to
invest in the space to build more
user-friendly and accessible tools
because there's a perception that hey
like the only people that use these like
really crappy tools are
criminals or people are like super
paranoid uh
and you know it's not a fair one-to-one
comparison if you're comparing like you
know
uh uber and tinder and gmail to like you
know
super underfunded like academic products
that
you know of course like you know your
average uh consumer doesn't want to use
right absolutely talk a little bit about
your partnership with one password and
kind of what that
uh is going to look like yeah so
um you know shortly after we announced
our api we started talking
with one password uh you know as a
company like we're
sort of very i think there's a lot of
sort of overlap in terms of like
uh where we'd like to see the world uh
you know one password what they're doing
with passwords there's a perfect analog
to what we're doing with cards
um and originally we started talking
about like maybe a co-marketing type
thing
or you know some way to sort of uh join
join forces to get the word out more to
more folks
um but you know over time like it was
like oh this is actually
something that we should just you know
integrate um and allow folks to generate
virtual cards from one password
uh and so that that sort of integration
actually came together really quickly
because we already had an api and they
were sort of
able to very uh quickly ingest and uh
you know
well integrate that api so
absolutely and in terms of
continuing that is that something where
you'll look for other partners to have
similar types of partnerships and
and can kind of grow uh you know
somewhat organically by by just kind of
getting this
uh through other distribution pipes
through those partnerships
yeah absolutely so our you know in terms
of like what we want to do as a company
we want to make
you know payments safer and easier for
everyone and that isn't necessa like
being
you know the go-to first-party app um
that's you know on you know the bottom
of your iphone or whatever it's not
neces
not really necessarily the way you know
we're dogmatic about doing it so
you know partnering with like-minded
companies uh and getting sort of
distribution
and um even you know a white label uh
approach is something that you know
we're very uh very much pursuing
absolutely what's the biggest challenge
for you guys right now
the challenge um from a company
perspective i think honestly the
the hardest thing has been adjusting to
like a fully remote
um setup uh you know i i think uh
this this gets glossed over sometimes
but um
people people people um often get a lot
of social interaction from from their
work
and um i think you know being remote and
starting a computer screen for eight
hours a day is like
not really the same as like you know the
an office human interaction so
um that's something that we're still
very much kind of adjusting to
and uh you know there's also stuff
around communication and like how do you
how do you make sure that everyone's on
the same page um as you're growing in
the remote world so
i think like many companies we're sort
of navigating that
absolutely before we get into the rapid
fire to uh wrap
this up uh what would just your pitch be
to users right so there's a bunch of
people who are listening to this
uh you've got the floor what is your
pitch on why they should use privacy.com
for virtual cards
yeah so the reason why you should use
this for virtual cards is we make your
life safer and more convenient
so we save you time and money um that's
that's what it comes down to
um you know everyone's had the
experience of like hey i signed up for
boiling wi-fi
uh six months ago and i'm just finding
out that they've been charging me
14 bucks a month or whatever it is uh
for the past couple months
um and so you know not only do we uh
you know save you time in making that
purchase a lot faster um we also
save you money in terms of like you know
forgetting to cancel transactions and so
on
uh that's pretty good pitch saying that
you're gonna save someone time and money
that tends to be uh something that
people are very interested in
yeah yeah before we wrap up i always ask
everyone the same two questions and then
you'll get to ask me one question at the
end
the first question is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
um it's a good question um
i am a listener uh of the podcast so i'm
gonna buck the trend a little bit
um i think a lot of folks say like an
early book that they read
uh and um there's a book that i read
recently called
out of the goby um it's by this uh
chinese private equity fund manager
uh and i think runs he managed it's now
like a 40 billion dollar
fund and what's interesting about is he
grew up during the cultural revolution
and basically spent six years of his
life uh instead of going to high school
and college
uh working doing hard manual labor out
in the gobi desert
i came to the us ended up getting his
phd and uh
now sort of is obviously super
successful um interesting for really
three reasons uh
the first being that uh obviously it's
super
super inspirational um you know i think
in a world where
uh youth is like kind of prioritized and
like everyone's like oh like if you
haven't made it by you know 25
or 30 uh you're kind of a failure right
um
i think it's really inspired and
inspiring to sort of hear about this
person that you know basically
uh lost six years of their their youth
uh and is
has still like you know been really
successful uh the second one on a
personal note
um that is uh really uh
resonated with me is you know my parents
came here as graduate students
uh and i think this is a piece of
chinese
history that doesn't really get talked
about very much
um and so it's this like whole
generation that kind of went through
this
um and it's it's like a really sort of
unvarnished perspective on that
um and um
you know i uh i feel like there's a
third no i'm blanking on it
um let's get let's come back i'll i'm
sure i'll think of the third thing
that's a great suggestion though i i
love books where
uh you can one learn about something two
there's like the inspiration and then
three also like there's a personal
connection to the book for you
right like i always you know after
asking so many people this question it's
like
very much uh what did the book mean to
them
more so than like this specific book is
the most important book in the world
right um and it's always interesting
usually it is time related
right so like you said you know earlier
in your life there's some formative
period they read some book
uh but but this one is uh sounds pretty
cool so i have to check it out for sure
uh second question aliens uh are you a
believer or a non-believer
um i yeah i i'm a believer
um yeah you know the the world is way
too big
for us to be you know is it you know a
carbon life form
is you know our aliens you know do
aliens you know walk and talk like us
like
probably not right but like alien life
forms like i
you know i would say like definitely
definitely do exist so
let me ask this question i've never
asked anyone this before but uh
just came to me do you think it's more
likely that
quote unquote some carbon life form
intelligent life whatever you want to
call it
is on like the moon slash
mars or do you think it's something
where it's
so far away that like you know it'll be
your grandkids grandkids grandkids
grandkids who even have a chance to
potentially
uh figure it out
um that is interesting
um that's a good question um
and i don't know the answer obviously
right but but it's like
you know is it something where it's
closer to us or it actually is really
really far away
yeah i i guess i would say i'm actually
long on both um so
explain that so so i think there's
there's there's a
feels like a reasonable likelihood that
there's like some you know if life came
from like a you know asteroid or
something like that um that it's also
like somewhere else in the ecosystem
uh in the in the solar system um but i
also
think that it's very likely you know
given how you know big the universe is
that
uh there there's life elsewhere too um
so
almost certainly there's life elsewhere
but i wouldn't be surprised if there was
uh life you know elsewhere in the solar
system but yeah
it's just fascinating to me to think
about uh
if it was both right like what and again
there's no
uh data that suggests this now but like
what if every planet had some form of
intelligent life on it
people's entire concept of space would
change
that yeah maybe it'd be mind-blowing
right
uh all right what question do you have
for me to uh wrap this up
um let's see
what is a uh
have you picked up a uh any sort of
uh postcovid or like you know durian
covered
uh like new york uh specific uh
habits like is has there been anything
there that's like really been like hey
like i really like this about like new
york city
yeah i was gonna say from like a habit
standpoint um
there's a couple of things so like one i
now every single day go on a walk uh
during like the hardcore like lockdown
component of covet it was more of like a
i gotta get out of my apartment you know
i can't sit here all day type thing
now it's more of like i enjoy it uh
planet and i go and uh and kind of walk
around
so that's uh nice um the second thing is
i've like really focused on
sleeping more um i don't
think that like i had anything that was
preventing me from doing it before it
just like wasn't a priority right and
like i mean i traveled a lot and that
kind of
screwed it up a little bit but like
that's been really nice to kind of like
say hey i'm gonna sleep at least eight
hours every single night
um and when you prioritize things
obviously you know you
you end up doing it um and then the only
other thing i would say is
just uh there's little things in new
york
that you or i probably took for granted
before
and so it's less about like some new
habit as much as it's like
man i really enjoyed doing x right and
so
you know like a kind of a easy one is um
i don't know if you've ever been to the
jp morgan library uh
right it's like one of my favorite
places in new york and
uh the other day i was talking to
clinton and i was just like
man i kind of want to go but like it
wasn't open
right and so you're just like like that
is so stupid
but yet at the same time like you start
to realize just how important that type
of stuff is
um so i think that's probably like the
things that i've
picked up what about yourself anything
that you specifically
uh like feel you picked up yeah um
it's really funny uh as you said like
going for walks uh
and sleeping more that's those are two
things that like i
i've like very much started doing um
and uh i i actually i got this um aura
kind of uh i guess plug uh
during drink of it and it's been like
actually really helpful
really my favorite uh fitness tracker i
guess
um the idea is uh in terms of like just
you know being able to kind of keep um
uh keep using it yeah
so so those are two two that definitely
resonate
um i think another thing that um
i've really enjoyed uh is just outdoor
dining um
it's it's one of these things where like
you know i just i kind of hope
stays uh you know in some capacity uh
so yeah my brother uh jews were talking
about it before
uh they built these like huge buildings
in the street and he's like they're not
taking those down
like like those business owners just
expanded their square footage are you
kidding me
yeah yeah totally i think i mean i think
like you know
but everyone i talk to likes it um the
businesses obviously like it
so i feel like those are those are
probably gonna stay
uh we'll just yeah we'll see though um
yeah
abs absolutely they just gotta figure
out how to keep them uh keep them warm
during the winter right
yeah yeah yeah so we'll see all right bo
listen
where can people find you on the
internet or find more about
uh privacy.com yeah for sure uh
surprise go to the website privacy.com
um i'm uh keep a pretty low profile
online but
um occasionally tweet at um bowling j
uh it's b-o-l-ing j um
yeah awesome well thank you so much for
doing this
everyone go check it out virtual cards
in my opinion
uh are a no-brainer i mean if you want
to basically keep your privacy and
security
uh you should probably use a virtual
card rather than the credit card in your
wallet or purse
uh so um you know go check it out
but uh we'll do this again in the future
my friend thank you so much yeah thanks
for having me